Hey, Veritasium! Michael [Stevens] from Vsauce here, and we're gonna ask some important questions.
Let's find some random bystanders...how about you?
Yes?
Michael: I don't believe you're scientifically literate.
Okay.
Michael: If a tomato is a fruit, does that mean ketchup is a smoothie?
John Green: So, can you name any of the cities in the Indus Valley civilization?
Are we talking about, like, Cairo?
John: (scoffs) Yeah, Cairo would not qualify as one of the cities in the Indus Valley civilisation.
John: Cairo!...Cairo!
This is Brady Haran from Periodic Videos,
and Sixty Symbols,
and bibledex,
and DeepSkyVideos,
and Numberphile,
and nottinghamscience,
and foodskey, and--
Alright, and I'm Derek from Veritasium.
Brady: Wait, you only got one channel?
I know!
Brady: You call yourself a Youtuber?
Vi Hart, uh, you want to ask me a question?
Vi: Triangle.
Um, that's not a question?
(laughs awkwardly)
Uh...ah-um...
John: In what year did the French Revolution began?
17...72?
John: You had the--the first two numbers were awesome!
(Derek chuckles)
Brady: We have a Veritasium exclusive right now.
We're gonna show you the first, unauthorized picture of CGP Grey, who's standing here right next to me.
Here's a question for--oh.
Hang on.
He was here a minute ago.
Henry Reich: Okay, so what I was thinking I might have you, uh, try to calculate here is some Feynman diagrams in curved spacetime.
But to start off with something a bit easier, uh, I think we should start off with the Christoffel symbol for the Schwartzchild metric.
Um, and in case you've forgotten I've written it, I've even written the metric here--
Derek: No, I know it--I know what it is. I don't need you to show me.
Henry: Okay.
Henry: So like--
Derek: No, I know it--I know what it is. I don't need you to show me.
Henry: I know.
Henry: You have something on your face.
Vi: Triangle, triangle, triangle, triangle, triangle, triangle, triangle, triangle, triangle.
Vi: Triangle, triangle, triangle...
I am actually quite concerned about what you're doing to my face.
Vi: (laughs) TRIANGLE!
Right, so this is CGP Grey and Veritasium at the BrainSTEM Conference here in Canada and it's been a great couple of days.
You gonna come visit me Derek?
Definitely! I've always wanted to visit Great Britain.
(CGP Grey sighs)
I mean...the United Kingdom?
England?
Derek: The British Isles?
CGP Grey: Great.
CGP Grey: Great, yeah. I look forward to it.
Going through U.S. customs in, like, an hour.
(Vi laughs)
I was expecting, like, ð˜¢ triangle, but this is feeling like lots of triangles.
Vi: Well, they--they're happier in groups.
Right.
Vi: Like, they're like sheep. They get sad and lonely by themselves.
Destin Sandlin: So, we're in the Corolla. I don't--I just met these guys.
Henry: Look, look, there's like the Mennonite farms out there.
If this car crashes right now, like, all of science on YouTube is going down.
(everyone laughs)